Good job coming here on your own.
Wasn't it dangerous for you?
What? It's not more dangerous
than Karino in that state.
Haha.
Anyway, do you need money that badly,
coming into work on a Sunday?
Haha. You're mistaken.
I just have work I need to finish
by the end of the day.
I come in on weekends every now and then.
I see, so you are busy.
Your face always seems glazed over.
You must be tired.
Haha.
Are you eating properly?
Eating is most important when you're busy.
Haha. This feels like counseling.
It's okay.
My wife takes care of me in that regard.
Huh?
You were able to get married?
Haha. What do you mean?
Well, you are quite skilled
at your job, after all.
"After all"?
By the way, I have kids too.
You should go home right now!
Your kids must be lonely
when you're working on a Sunday.
Okay, you should go!
Haha. You're hitting a sore spot.
Want to take a field trip?
Huh?
We have an editing department
for a kids' toy magazine.
There are some pretty interesting items.
I do not require a field trip.
I believe there's also
some Tonosaman merchandise.
It can't be helped.
If you allow me to view just that,
I'll leave shortly thereafter.
Haha.
Well, Sir Fukuno,
you must be satisfied showing me this.
Hurry up and go home now.
Haha. He can't take his eyes off this.
There's also
a big game machine over there.
I don't need video games. I'm going home.
Do you like it?
Don't misunderstand me. I am just
checking the condition of the machine.
Haha.
Speaking of which, I believe
we have a two meter tall Tonosaman doll.
This is the Happy Dance Tonosaman
that was on display
at the anime anniversary event!
It's my first time seeing it in person!
It is amazing!
Sir Fukuno,
you should not be entertaining me.
Isn't this a disservice to your children?
Hmm. He's a tough nut to crack.